so many people love Donald Trump
intensely so many people hate Donald
Trump intensely there is a large number
of Americans who don't feel very
strongly about Donald Trump and I think
it's those people who will decide the
election um they probably don't like him
very much as a person but then they're
going to look at the economy and think
you know was it better then than it is
now and they may well say yes so
obviously in such a huge country you
have enormous differing views of Donald
Trump I think the thing to remember is
that if you speak to most Americans uh
they won't be as passionate about Donald
Trump as probably the people you see in
the media